Professor Robert
Shiller: First thing,
I wanted just to--I forgot to
show--I don't know how exciting
this is, but this is a ticker
tape.
They weren't brown.
This tape is about a
half-century old.
It came from the attic of the
New York Stock Exchange.
When I was at a conference
there a year ago,
I mentioned to the vice
president there that I had told
my class about ticker tape
machines and they had never
heard of them--didn't know what
they were;
well, at least some of them
hadn't.
So, he sent me this.
This was never used,
but normally it would go into a
machine and it would print out
stock prices at trades.
I was giving a talk yesterday
at the New York Stock Exchange
and I met him again and I said,
thank you for this;
my class was happy to see it.
He said, well I could have
given you a whole ticker tape
machine.
He said, well the attic at the
New York Stock Exchange was
filled with them,
but they finally threw them
out, so it's too late.
I think it is--this is evidence
that information technology
really has dominated stock
prices.
We didn't really have active
stock markets before the
electronic age,
which is an interesting thing
to think about because the
ticker tape machine was invented
by Edison in 1867.
In 1867, there were hardly
any--there were stock markets,
but they were very small.
It was really the electronic
communications that made it what
it is.
It's exciting to think about
the future and where electronic
communication is going to take
markets going forward.
I wanted to continue today
about our futures markets.
Let me just step back and
think, what is a futures market?
Today, I'm going to talk about
how it has expanded to cover
lots of other things,
notably financial instruments.
Let's just think,
what is a futures market?
If you read Holbrook Working,
who's on your reading list,
and his half-century old paper,
back in those days that he was
writing, he says that the name
"futures" is a bit misleading
because that suggests that it's
talking about the future rather
than today.
If you listen to the news about
any commodity price,
it's always talking about
futures price.
They don't talk about the price
today.
The futures price is the
interesting--the point that
Working made is not so much that
it's in the future is that it's
well-defined and standardized.
For agricultural futures,
it's true that the contract
doesn't mature for a month or
so,
but as Working points out,
any contract for delivery of
something has some term.
They don't just deliver it
instantly and Working says,
there are times when the
so-called spot price is actually
further in the future than the
futures price.
If you look at the way things
are traded--I'm going to be
talking a lot about oil,
but let me just talk generally
about oil.
What is the price of oil and
how does anybody know what it
is?
If you go to people who buy and
sell oil, they will tell you,
well we don't just sell oil;
we don't just have it ready to
go.
Almost all of the oil is sold
in long-term contracts,
so an oil company will sell a
contract to deliver regularly to
some refinery,
oil.
They'll have these tankers
appear and we sign a five-year
contract--or whatever--and it
has all kinds of terms.
If you read the contract it
would be fifty pages long and it
would specify all kinds of "what
we'll do if we don't deliver" or
"what happens if we can't
deliver the grade we promised."
Lots of uncertainties are
defined, so who knows what the
price of oil is when it's being
part of a long-term contract.
That's why you need a futures
market and the futures market is
the market that's free of--it
has a standardized contract.
We know exactly what the price
means and attention focuses on
the futures market because the
trade there is--everybody
understands it;
everyone knows exactly what's
being traded.
The minute-to-minute changes
reflect something;
they reflect something real,
namely change in the market not
any change in what's being
delivered.
Anyway, it used to be that the
only futures markets were for
commodities--for
things--typically it was thought
that futures markets are good to
have for things that are not
standardized--that are difficult
to define.
So, we want rice futures and we
want wheat futures because there
are so many different kinds of
rice in different areas and
different--so,
we want to have a standardized
price.
There were no financial futures
until the 1970s and people felt
back then that we don't need
futures contracts because
there's a standardization of
shares.
Every share in a given company
is exactly identical.
When you say,
I'd like to buy a hundred
shares of a company,
you're not going to ask the
broker, well which shares did I
get?
And can I look at them?
Your broker would say in
disbelief, look you've got
shares;
they're all absolutely
identical.
You might think there's no need
for a futures market because the
prices are already standardized
in the cash market.
Moreover, the prices that you
see traded on the stock exchange
floor--you know exactly when the
trade took place;
they're not future-traded.
Why did we get futures markets?
Let me come back to that.
Let me just first--why did we
get stock futures markets?
Let me come back to that and
talk about--let's be clear what
they are.
Stock index futures markets
came in around 1980 and one of
the very first was the Standard
& Poor 500 Stock Index
Futures Market traded at the
Chicago Mercantile Exchange.
It was a radical innovation
when it came in because people
thought, what's the point?
I can see farmers delivering
their corn or their oats or
whatever, but stocks--what's the
point?
Well, it turned out to be
absolutely right because--the
CME was absolutely right to
create this market
because--within a few years,
there was more trade on the
futures market than there was on
the stock market itself.
Let's be clear what they
created--and this is the terms
of the contract as it is today.
The S&P 500 is an index of
stock prices produced by
Standard &
Poor's Corporation and
it's--they take the prices of
500 stocks and they form a
weighted average.
It's an arithmetic average
where the weights correspond to
the amounts outstanding of the
various stocks,
so it's a value-weighted index.
It's just a number published by
the American Stock Exchange--no,
by Standard &
Poor's.
All it is at--just as with
agricultural futures--I don't
know how clear I was about this
yesterday.
If you--maybe I didn't say this.
Let me say that it applies to
both agricultural futures and
financial futures.
If you want to trade in the
futures market,
you have to put up margin and
there's a margin requirement for
each contract.
The margin is there to
eliminate counterparty risk with
other contracts.
When you sign a contract with
another person you have to worry
whether that person will come
through,
but with the exchange that
counterparty risk is eliminated.
The way the exchange eliminates
it is it takes the other side
itself--of every contract
who--it stands between you and
the counterparty and it protects
itself by demanding margin.
You have to,
up front, put up margin for any
futures contract and the margin
is settled daily.
Every day, they look at your
margin account and they adjust
it.
So, if--let me go back to wheat
futures because that's the
simpler--I don't think I really
explained this well.
If you buy--when we say "buy
wheat futures," what does that
mean?
That means--the word buy or
sell has a different meaning in
futures markets.
When you buy wheat futures or,
for that matter,
S&P 500 in futures,
it means that you put up
margin.
You did not pay the price for
the contract;
you only paid margin,
which might be 5% or less than
the price.
If you're buying wheat futures,
what are you doing?
You're putting up margin and
standing ready to see your
margin account credited or
debited depending on the change
in the futures price from day to
day.
If the price of wheat in the
futures market goes up and you
bought futures,
they will increase your margin
account by the amount that it
went up.
If the price of wheat goes
down, they will decrease your
margin account balance by that
amount.
How do they get the money?
Well, that's because for every
buyer there's a seller in the
futures market,
so somebody else sold futures.
Both of you put up margin;
if you are buying,
you put up margin;
if you are selling,
you put up margin.
So, the result is that they
have a place to get the money.
If the price goes up and you
bought, your margin account will
go up.
The exchange will get the money
by taking it from the margin
account of the guy who sold and
they've always fixed it so that
the number of buyers always
equals the number of sellers.
You see how the exchange can't
lose and you can't lose;
this is a guaranteed thing.
The only problem is that what
if a margin account runs dry?
Both buyer and seller have put
up margin and then the
price--let's say the price drops
a lot;
the futures price drops a lot.
Then, that means that the
buyer's margin account is wiped
out.
What will happen then is that
the futures commission merchant
will go to the person who bought
the futures and say,
do you want to post more margin
or do you want me to close you
out?
That person has a decision to
make and if he or she puts up
more margin, then that
replenishes the margin account
and the person can keep trading.
That's how the exchanges
eliminate counterparty risk,
by daily resettlement of the
contracts.
It's an invention--actually
goes back to Japan;
although, it was slightly
different in form.
It's an invention that
eliminates any risk of the
counterparty not performing so
that risk doesn't affect price.
So it's the same--are you clear
on that now--how the margin
account works?
You might not enjoy this.
Depends on how much of a
gambling instinct for how much
fun this is.
If you buy or sell futures,
you can expect a phone call
from your broker sooner or
later;
well, not necessarily,
unless you have incredibly good
luck.
Hillary Clinton,
when she invested in the
futures market,
she had incredibly good luck.
You know this story?
When her husband,
Bill Clinton,
was Governor,
she got a call from--a friend
recommended to her a very good
broker who knew how to trade in
commodity futures.
So, she put up something like
$1,000 of her own money and then
the broker kept calling her and
asking her what she wanted to
do.
She just never lost anything;
she turned it into a $100,000
within a year and then she
stopped.
We don't know why--I'm not
anti-Hillary Clinton;
this is just a futures market
story.
I like her a lot,
but what do you think happened
there?
Her margin account just kept
going up, and up,
and up.
I mean, it went up amazingly.
You could conclude that she is
a brilliant trader and she ought
to be President of the United
States, but then the next
question is, why did she stop?
Why did she run it for a
hundred-fold increase and stop?
Does anyone have any idea?
Is this common knowledge--this
story?
Well, the story ends there;
nobody knows what happened.
Futures traders are willing to
exercise a guess of what
happened.
Does anyone have any guess what
you think happened?
Well, I shouldn't say things so
political.
I do like Hillary Clinton,
but what likely happened is
some futures commission merchant
was thinking of bribing the
Governor.
Maybe he didn't--never actually
did it--but let's do a little
favor for his wife and then
maybe I can ask him for
something later.
So, the futures merchant just
didn't listen carefully to what
she said.
He just--well,
he sort of cooked the books and
gave her money by making it look
like a trade.
When she found out--what
finally likely happened is
someone said,
do you think you're making so
much money in the futures
market?
Remember who your husband is
and this guy--do you trust him?
This is a likely guess.
She finally wondered,
what is going on here?
And she stopped because she
didn't know what was happening
either.
Somehow money was coming in
and--that's the very--now,
maybe she was just very savvy
in her investing ability,
but usually your futures
accounts go both up and down and
you get margin calls.
Anyway, the last day of the
contract there's a settlement
and--in agricultural futures,
the last day there's delivery
if you're still in the contract.
If you are a seller on the last
day, you must deliver the
specified number of barrels or
bushels of whatever it is.
Or, if you are a buyer,
you must take delivery of them.
With stock futures it's
different because nobody expects
you to deliver shares of stock.
What happens on the last day is
there's a final settlement and
that is in dollars in this
case--250 times the S&P 500
Index on the last day minus the
futures price of the preceding
day;
that's the settlement.
Of course, you have been
gaining the changes in the
futures prices every preceding
day.
If you--this is what you
receive as a buyer if you bought
the contract and this is what
you pay if you sold the
contract.
Everyday between the time you
originally bought,
you've been getting--if you
were a buyer--the change in the
futures price and at the end you
get this.
If you sum all those up--all
the settlements you got since
you bought the contract until
the expiration of the
contract--you would be getting
the index at time T minus
the futures when you bought.
That defines it.
Everyday you get the change in
the futures price;
those all add up into your
margin account and on the last
day you get this.
What is it, really,
you're doing?
You could say--and they
wouldn't like to put this way at
the futures exchanges;
they don't like gambling
analogies, but I make gambling
analogies freely in this course.
It's like placing a bet on the
stock market.
If you think the stock market
is going to go up,
you buy the futures,
and if you think it's going to
go down, you sell the futures.
If you buy one contract,
how much money do you get?
You get, in total,
over the total interval,
between the purchase date and
the expiration of the contract,
you get the stock index minus
the initial futures price you
paid, times $250;
that's the gamble.
If you sell,
it's just exactly the opposite.
Now, there's something called
fair value and you'll see this
talked about a lot in futures.
This is what the futures price
should be;
we talked about it in terms of
wheat.
Remember, the fair value of a
wheat futures was equal to the
price of wheat today times one
plus the interest rate,
plus the storage costs;
that was the formula we had
last time.
That was the fair value because
we concluded that somebody who's
storing grain has to make their
expenses,
they have to make the interest
cost and they have to make the
storage costs,
so the futures price should be
equal to fair value.
It's the same here with stock
index futures.
The fair value F of a
futures contract is equal to the
stock price plus the stock price
times the interest rate,
plus the storage cost.
The storage cost for stocks is
negative because it doesn't cost
you anything to store a stock.
Well, you don't even have to
store certificates anymore;
your name will be held
electronically.
It's negative because you get
dividends.
So, y is the dividend
yield that you get on the stock.
So r minus y is
the adjustment you have to make.
You see this--to get from stock
price to fair value--you see
this is the same formula that we
had for wheat,
except that you understand that
storage costs for stocks are
negative because they pay a
dividend.
So, all I've done is I've--the
way I wrote it before was P x
(1 + r + s) in the
preceding lecture;
now it's P x (1 + r
– y) because s =
-y.
That's the fair value of a
stock index futures.
Now, we said last time that
sometimes prices deviate from
fair value--or maybe they don't
depending on how you define fair
value.
But, if you define fair value
as 1 + r + s, where
s is just the cost of a
warehouse,
then sometimes that formula
doesn't work because we talked
about last time,
at the end of the growing
season nobody is storing wheat
anymore.
So, the wheat market falls into
backwardation and the futures
price gets low.
Other than that--normally wheat
is being stored,
so normally wheat prices are
essentially equal to fair value,
but stocks are always being
stored.
There's no--it would be unusual
to see backwardation in this
market;
it would be abnormal because
we're always storing stocks.
That's what we do with them is
we hold them.
Dividend yield--you can have
backwardation,
however, if the dividend yield
is greater than the interest
rate because then the adjustment
would make the futures price
below the cash price.
Otherwise, you can't have
backwardation in this market,
so price should always equal
fair value.
Right now, we're in an unusual
circumstance where the interest
rate and the dividend yield are
about the same.
Right now, the Fed has cut
short-term interest
rates--federal funds rate--to
2.25%;
that's very close to the
dividend yield on the S&P
500.
So, at this point of time,
the futures price is very close
to the spot price,
so fair value calculations are
relatively unimportant.
Are there any questions?
Do you understand this?
I have a clipping from--I took
it from yesterday's Wall
Street Journal and this is
to prove that The Wall Street
Journal is still publishing
financial data even though
they've cut way back.
This used to be a longer entry,
but this is what they have as
of yesterday.
This says the Standard &
Poor 500--this is under futures
prices--Chicago Mercantile
Exchange--and they're reminding
you that the settlement is 250
times the index and they show
two contracts,
one expiring in June and one
expiring in December.
These are the prices;
this is the opening price at
the beginning of the day;
this is the highest price for
the day that the contracts
traded;
this is the lowest price traded
for the day;
and this is the settled price,
which is essentially the last
price of the day.
This is the change in the
settled from the preceding day
and this is the open interest;
it's 550,000 contracts.
Do you understand what all this
means?
Now, interesting,
it looks like there's
backwardation because the
December futures at open is
lower than the June futures,
but I think this must be--it's
not much lower.
I think it may have something
to do with timing of the trades.
If you look at the settled
price over here they are almost
exactly identical between June
and December.
It's not backwardation;
it's contango--the futures is
above--it's going up as the
horizon goes out.
That's where we are today and
they talk an awful lot about
futures--stock index futures.
If you watch CNBC,
they're always talking about it
and the reason is is that it's
such a big and liquid market.
In fact, the futures
market--the S&P futures
market--as I said,
it's gotten bigger than the
stock market itself,
at least at certain times.
It's also just a more
trustworthy number and it moves
faster, so it's gotten a great
deal of attention.
Why does the future market move
so fast and why is it such a
popular instrument?
I think the main reason is that
it is a market that--it's like a
wholesale market for antiques
rather than the local antique
dealer.
If you went to an antique
dealer in New Haven to try to
buy some furniture for your
apartment who knows what price
you would get;
it would be very erratic and
you'd be dealing one-on-one with
the dealer.
Well, that's what happens in
the futures--in the stock market
as well.
Remember, I was telling you
that a dealer has to have a
bid-asked spread.
An antique dealer--they'll buy
the chest of drawers at a lower
price then they'll sell it and
the difference between bid and
asked is their bid-asked spread
and that's their profit.
Dealers have to keep a wide
bid-asked spread because they
have a lot of expenses and they
have the risk of being ripped
off by more knowledgeable people
who really know antiques and
will buy their best stuff and
leave behind the junk.
Because they're constantly
exposed to this risk antique
dealers keep wide bid-asked
spreads.
It's the same with the stock
market.
The people--the specialists or
the dealers who trade on the
stock market with customers have
the same concerns,
so they keep relatively wide
bid-asked spreads.
In the futures market,
there is--it's cleaner.
There's a huge volume of trade;
it's very competitive;
and there's less fear about
being ripped off by someone who
has special knowledge because
who knows what this index is
going to do anyway.
So, dealers have narrow
bid-asked spreads in the futures
market and, as a result,
the futures market is where the
action is.
The people who doubted that
back in 1980--who doubted that
financial futures would ever
take off--were really wrong.
Even though stocks are
perfectly standardized--every
share is the same as every other
share--we do need a futures
market,
so the futures market is very
important.
Anyway, I wanted to talk about
oil.
Are there any questions about
oil--about stock futures?
I went through it kind of
quickly, but the important thing
to know is just to understand
fair value.
It's actually a very simple
market to understand.
Once you know this formula you
pretty much know the price for
any future date.
Remember the r again,
as in the preceding lecture,
is not the annual interest rate
unless we're talking about a
contract that matures in one
year.
It's the interest between now
and the expiration date and the
same thing with dividends.
This is the dividend yield
where we're not talking about
annual dividend yield,
but the dividends as a fraction
of the price between now and
maturity of the contract.
That's the only formula that we
really need.
Let's think of the stock index
futures market;
it's where you really look to
see where the stock market is
moving.
It's faster than the stock
price index itself that the
S&P publishes.
The S&P 500 is a little bit
behind the thing that it's
trading on.
Why is that?
Well, that's because some of
the stocks in the S&P 500
Index don't trade really
minute-by-minute with the same
speed that you'd think,
so the S&P 500 is always
catching up on itself--the
actual index.
This market has all the
smartest traders trading it and
they kind of know when the
S&P 500 is lagging and they
immediately correct it in the
futures price.
The futures price is the place
to look for what the stock
market is really doing.
I'll move to oil futures,
which is a matter of great
interest right now because of
the turmoil in the oil market.
Oil futures actually go
back--they're not so old either
compared to wheat or corn;
they developed in the early
1980s.
This is the NYMEX oil futures
market and there are many
futures markets for oil,
but the NYMEX is the most
important one.
They are trading--this is
different--it's a physical
delivery oil futures market,
no different from the
agricultural futures.
They define a particular grade
of oil and they call it light,
sweet crude oil.
Sweet oil is better than sour
oil.
I wouldn't try tasting it,
but the refiners like it better
generally.
So, it's a grade of oil;
it's also called West Texas
Intermediate.
You have to--if you buy a
contract and you hold it to
maturity, you are going to have
to take delivery of 1,000
barrels of light,
sweet crude oil in Cushing,
Oklahoma.
They pick Cushing,
Oklahoma as kind of central to
the country.
You could call your broker and
buy a contract today and then
you could get the May contract.
Then, in May you'd have to take
a trip down to Cushing and get
your 1,000 barrels or you could
sell in the futures market and
that would mean that you would
have--you would be promising to
deliver 1,000 barrels.
As I said last time,
almost nobody who trades these
contracts actually takes
delivery or makes delivery
because almost everyone closes
out their contract before that.
It's the same idea as all the
other oil contracts.
You have contracts maturing in
each month, there's one--we're
already--we've already passed
the expiration of the April
contract,
so it's May,
June, July, August,
etc., and this is the price.
These are--well actually,
they make a distinction between
last and settled.
The settled price is the
important price because that
determines the changes in your
margin account.
The settled price as of
yesterday reached $113.44 per
barrel, which is a record high.
You can see that as delivery
dates go out the settled price
goes down, so the oil market is
currently in backwardation.
Now, remember what we said
about futures is that normally
they're in contango.
Remember, the futures price
fair value tends to equal the
price today, times one,
plus the interest rate,
plus storage costs.
Storage costs for oil are
substantial;
this is a thick,
bulky commodity.
You've got to have one of those
storage tanks;
you see them out there in New
Haven Harbor.
They cost money;
it's expensive to store,
so storage costs are not
negligible for oil;
plus, interest rates are
positive.
We would think that oil should
have contango normally.
Its price should be going up,
but very frequently oil is not
in contango;
right now it is not.
You can see that oil prices are
lower by October,
according to the futures
market.
I wanted to reflect a little
bit on what oil--what is going
on in the oil market.
The thing you have to
understand in terms of what--you
understand the contract;
it's exactly the same as a
wheat contract.
It's just a contract to deliver
1,000 barrels or receive it and
if you do that you don't have to
come up with oil today.
You probably never come up oil;
you just have to come up with
margin today and your margin
account will reflect the change
in oil prices.
This is the number you see in
the newspaper.
This is when they talk about
the price of oil in the
newspaper;
this is it.
There's also something called
Platts, which is a company
that--I guess it's a McGraw-Hill
Company--that does cash prices
of oil.
It's not quoted as much because
I don't think it's as reliable
as this.
The problem with--you might
say, this is a month in the
future.
Isn't that--that's not today's
price, but that's what people
are quoting as today's price
because it's the most accurate
price.
Now, why is it going into
backwardation?
I wanted to think about storage
of oil because we were saying
that everything should be
generally in contango.
Aren't they storing oil?
As I said, if you drive out to
New Haven Harbor you see all
these storage tanks.
Don't they have oil in them?
I wanted to think a little bit
about where the oil is.
Most of the oil is still in the
ground in the Persian Gulf,
in Mexico, in Russia,
and all sorts of places,
but we don't count that as
storage of oil because it has to
be extracted and it's not just
there for sale--there's a lag.
So, we have to consider oil
that's above ground and ready to
go.
It is stored and it's stored
here in New Haven.
In fact, the Government of the
United Stated has created what
they call a "strategic petroleum
reserve."
It has taken oil and it's
storing it in caverns,
in caves, and this is in case
of a national emergency where we
suddenly really need oil.
That isn't going to affect this
market because it's being held
by the Government for some war
or some terrible event.
It's not on the market,
so that doesn't affect
the--even though the market is
in backwardation the Government
is not going to sell off this
oil,
so it's not affecting the
market.
The other thing that's happened
is there's a heating oil
reserve;
this was created by President
Clinton in the year 2000.
That is actually in two places;
it's in New York and New Haven.
So, we are the storage place
for heating oil.
This is not a strategic
petroleum reserve,
but it's the reserve that the
Government can use to stabilize
the heating oil market.
They were concerned about
spikes in heating oil affecting
people who are in difficult
economic circumstances.
That reserve could ultimately
affect the market if the
government chooses to sell it
off, but they only have two
million barrels,
so it's not big.
I think the first thing to
recognize about the oil market
is that there isn't much storage
compared to the flow through.
Basically, what we have in oil
is we have those wells all over
the world pumping oil.
They put it into tankers;
the tankers take it across the
ocean to various countries where
it goes into temporary storage
at harbors, but it doesn't stay
there long.
It keeps flowing through,
then it's put on oil trucks and
it's driven to refineries and
then it ends up in gas stations.
So, there's not a lot of oil in
storage.
That's why the oil market is
very often in backwardation,
because the price of oil
reflects the temporary
scarcities of oil.
If there's any shortage of oil,
if something happens,
then the oil price can jump up
and everybody knows it's going
to come back down;
so, you can have backwardation.
Basically, you don't have
people selling off their stores
when there's a backwardation
like we talked about last time.
It's not like at the end of the
harvest people know--when the
wheat harvest is coming in,
people know that wheat prices
should go down and they sell off
their stores;
it's not like that here.
The stores that we have of oil
are--have a convenience yield,
so it's something that
doesn't--backwardation doesn't
quickly correct itself.
I think that what this means
here--this backwardation in the
oil market--is that people think
that oils have spiked up,
there's a temporary shortage,
and that prices are going to
come down somewhat,
although not a whole lot here.
This is a futures term
structure;
I have it plotted for a number
of years.
I should have made this a
little bigger;
it's a little hard to read.
This is today.
What this is for--all of these
are from today's news on this
top line and what it shows is,
for every maturity out to six
years, what the futures price
is.
Right now, we're at $114 a
barrel, but the market is
predicting a decline.
Not a huge decline,
but back to something like $108
a barrel in six years.
You can see that the futures
market has often been predicting
either increases or declines.
You can look at different times
in history;
particularly of interest here I
have Hurricane Katrina and I
can't--this is Hurricane
Katrina.
Right after the hurricane,
in August of 2005,
the hurricane destroyed some of
our refining capability and some
of our storage tanks because New
Orleans is an oil center where
tankers come and they go up the
Mississippi River.
We destroyed--the hurricane
destroyed part of our
infrastructure,
so everybody in the market knew
that that means that oil prices
are temporarily high;
so, you can see the
backwardation in the market.
We see even more backwardation
today;
that's an indication that
there's something going on in
the short run in our market,
if you believe the market.
What do I have?
I have here--this goes way
back--this one is 1990.
You notice it stops after
eighteen months;
that's because in 1990 the
futures market wasn't as
developed as it is now;
it only went out eighteen
months.
You can see there was strong
backwardation.
This was when Saddam Hussein
invaded Kuwait and it caused a
tremendous disruption of oil
supply and everybody knew that
was temporary,
so the futures prices were
lower.
That was about the most
backward-dated futures market
we've seen in oil.
Today it's pretty
backward-dated,
but not so dramatically
percentage-wise,
as it was after Katrina.
This is a plot of oil prices in
the United States.
This is West Texas Intermediate.
Well actually,
I'm not sure it's all the way
back--is West Texas--no,
it's not all the way because
Texas Oil wasn't discovered
until around 1900,
I think;
I'm not sure about that date
exactly.
This is Pennsylvania Oil back
here;
I've got it going way back.
The interesting thing about
this--this is of interest at the
moment--that oil prices now are
higher than they've ever been
and this is in real terms--real,
inflation-corrected terms.
Very interesting what this
means for our lives;
just ten years ago oil was at a
record low.
We were at a little over $10 a
barrel.
So, what is going on here?
We've seen the oil price jump
up something close to ten-fold
in ten years;
it's a huge surprise.
There are other surprises.
One thing I wanted to do was to
go through just a few--go
through a few stories about oil
prices here.
This was a period when oil was
generally very stable.
In the post World War II
period, there was a Texas
Railroad Commission that was
stabilizing oil prices.
At that time,
the U.S.
was not a big importer of oil;
we had our own oil supply and
we tended to--we had sort of a
monopoly that tried to stabilize
the price and they were pretty
successful for this long time
period.
The huge shock came--and this
is called the first oil
shock--and that was in 1973-74.
Oil went up;
it more than doubled--almost
three times increase in oil
prices all of a sudden.
That was associated with a
particular--it's called the
first oil crisis--and it
coincides with the Yom Kippur
War between Israel and her Arab
neighbors.
It caused a--Israel quickly
triumphed in that war,
but it left a lot of bad
feelings among the surrounding
Arab countries who were
sympathetic with the Palestinian
cause,
so they cut back on their oil
production.
We have an organization called
OPEC--that's the Organization of
Petroleum Exporting
Countries--and it was
established in 1960 with a small
number of Arab countries,
but it has gradually grown and
has more and more countries that
are members.
It was OPEC that constrained
the supply of oil for the first
oil crisis.
This is the second oil crisis
here and that was in 1979-80.
This again had its origin--at
least the common story and there
must be some truth to the story.
It had its origin in another
crisis in the Middle East and
that was the war between Iraq
and Iran.
There was an Iranian revolution
in 1979, where the Shah of Iran
was thrown out and the Ayatollah
Khomeini came in and Iraq used
this as an opportunity to try to
grab some oil from Iran.
This war completely disrupted
oil supplies and we had this
huge spike in oil prices then.
A lot of these spikes seem to
have political causes;
this spike in the oil price is
caused by the 1991 invasion of
the--well, the United States was
the primary invader of Iraq.
This was after September 11th
and this disrupted oil supplies
again.
All these times were periods of
backwardation in the oil market
because people saw them as
crises that were limiting the
supply of oil for now,
but would eventually correct
themselves.
What's happening now?
This is just an amazing spike
of oil right now.
There isn't--we have this war
in Iraq, but it's not a sudden,
intense thing that--it's not
disrupting oil supplies.
So, why are we seeing this huge
spike in oil?
That is an interesting question.
Part of it has to do with the
fact that we have a rapidly
growing world economy and
developing countries are moving
forward faster than was
anticipated.
So, there's a lot of demand for
oil from India,
China, and other rapidly
developing countries.
They say that China builds a
new city the size of Houston,
Texas every month,
so they're consuming an awful
lot of energy to do this.
The other side of it is that
discoveries of oil have been
disappointing.
I was just down in Mexico and
the President Calderon is
talking about privatizing the
Mexican oil--or at least part of
it--oil industry because they
have been disappointing in their
exploration.
They're not finding oil,
so the reserves that Mexico has
been actually declining rapidly.
This brings up another thing
about the ownership of oil.
I just wanted to mention
nationalization.
It used to be that most of the
oil in the world was owned by
private companies or
individuals,
but nationalization began in
1938 in Mexico,
where a left-leaning government
decided that all the Mexican oil
that was owned by foreigners
really belonged to the Mexican
people.
So, the Mexican government just
said, it's ours.
That was an outrageous thing to
say then, but it was greeted by
shock by international law.
They just took the oil in their
country, saying that it wasn't
fair the way it was sold.
It was followed up in 1951 by
Iran and other countries
followed as well.
Now we're seeing a reverse.
Mexico nationalized its oil in
1938, but now that the supply is
dwindling, President Calderon
wants to reverse the process;
this is controversial now.
In yesterday's newspaper--I
don't know if you read The
Wall Street Journal--it had
a story saying that Russian--for
the first quarter of 2008,
Russian production of oil
declined for the first time in
ten years.
There's worry now that Russia
is running out of oil.
I think it's these--this impact
of--news like this is having a
psychological effect on the
market and it's causing a huge,
well, you might consider this a
bubble in oil prices,
but I'm not so sure that it's a
bubble.
It's certainly unprecedented.
It seems like we're entering a
period of great market
volatility.
We've seen an unprecedented
bubble in home prices and now
the economy is reeling from the
effects of this bubble.
Look what's happening,
as well, in oil prices.
Once again, there's no war
right now;
there's nothing really dramatic.
We do have--you could call it a
war, but it's not something that
has shut down the Persian Gulf
and closed off oil supplies.
So, it seems like it's
something more systemic.
It's something more to do with
the economic situation than
before or it's something
speculative.
We have--so we have
backwardation,
but it's not a whole lot of
backwardation.
They're still predicting oil
prices to come down to something
like there--well over $100 in
eight years--so it's not a--it's
not something that's related to
a particular crisis that is
going to end quickly.
I wanted to go--this just is a
clipping I got from--this was
the day that Saddam Hussein
announced an oil embargo.
This was his reaction to the
United States' pressure on him
and so oil prices spiked up.
It seemed dramatic when I made
this clipping,
but now oil is $100 a barrel;
that's only six years ago,
but at that time people
thought--the market thought that
oil prices were coming back down
by '03.
They were really wrong;
people didn't get it.
All this time,
people thought that oil--a
large part of the time it was in
backwardation.
They thought there was some
special event occurring--this is
Saddam Hussein--but it turns out
that there was something driving
it up.
This is again--this is natural
gas on that same date.
This is still in contango
because the prices are going up
through time,
so that kind of explains if
Saddam Hussein was selectively
hitting on the oil market and
not the natural gas market;
that explains those two markets.
I wanted to talk briefly about
other futures.
There's a gold futures market
and the gold futures
market--this is an old clipping
I had of a very steady contango
market.
That's because gold is very
different than oil.
Gold is in storage.
There's nothing to do with gold
except hold it.
You don't burn it.
That's the difference;
oil you burn it and it's gone,
so we don't have much around
and we're always vulnerable to
some supply interruption.
But with gold,
there's no supply interruption;
we don't burn gold;
it just sits there and we're
holding this stuff.
We don't know what to do with
that.
It can't really be in contango
for very long because someone
who's holding gold is going to
say,
hey if it's going down in the
futures market I'm not going to
sit on this stuff;
I'm going to sell it.
It stays in--did I say contango?
If it's in backwardation people
would sell it.
It stays very nicely in
contango and it's going up at
the rate of interest.
The storage--there's a storage
cost as well,
but I don't know how big that
is for gold.
I guess you'd have to pay for a
police force to defend your
gold--something like that.
So, it must have some storage
costs, but it's a very simple
market because it stays in
contango all the time.
Copper futures--now copper is
different from gold because it's
not--this is a 2004 clipping
again.
Copper is an industrial
commodity that gets used up,
so it suffers from supply
disruptions and it can--like
oil--it can fall into
backwardation.
Here, I should write these--did
I ever write these down?
Contango, just to make sure,
is when futures prices are
going up as the maturity--with
maturity;
higher prices for more future
dates.
Backwardation is when it's
going down.
This is an example of a
backwardated market.
The prices as we go out to
further and further--this is
2004--when we go out to December
of that year,
it's down from $139 to $136.
When we go out to December of
the following year,
it's down to $118.
Gold, by the way,
has gone up a lot too.
There's been a lot of commodity
price increases that surprised
us.
This is the federal funds
futures--another clipping.
There's a futures market for
the federal funds rate and it's
cash-settled because you can't
deliver federal funds.
The settlement--the price shown
is $100 minus the federal funds
rate.
So back then--this is 2004--the
federal funds rate was about 5%.
So, this looks like 5.25%,
so $100 minus $94.74 is 5.25%;
that's what the federal funds
rate was expected to be in March
of 2004.
Here you see that the federal
funds rate was expected to
continue to decline at that
time.
This market can go either way
because you don't store federal
funds, so there's no fair value
calculation like there are with
the other markets.
It reflects the expectations of
future interest rates.
Right now, I don't--I should
have gotten today's,
but I think the federal funds
futures market is predicting
right now,
with the federal funds rate at
2.25%, the federal funds
market--this would be $97.75,
or $100 minus 2.25%;
or it would be close to that
and it would be going down with
time.
People are expecting the Fed to
cut interest rates--I'm sorry,
these numbers would be going
up, but I don't have the
clipping for today.
I just finally wanted to talk
about home price futures,
which is a market that I've
gotten involved with creating at
the Chicago Mercantile Exchange.
I got involved with them
because I have a price index.
My colleague and I,
Karl Case, who's a professor at
Wellesley College--he and I,
in the late 1980s,
created a home price index.
This was our research;
we put it out as a working
paper here at Yale twenty years
ago.
From the beginning,
we thought that the real
importance of having a home
price index is for trading.
We live in a world where people
don't trade--there's no
international market for real
estate.
It's quite remarkable that
there is not because real estate
is a huge asset class.
The value of single-family
homes in this country is about
30% bigger than the value of the
stock market in the U.S.;
yet, we see so much talk about
the stock market.
When we started in 1988 we
realized not only was there no
market for single family homes,
except the very local market,
there was also no price index
for single family homes.
It's just sometimes amazing how
undeveloped things are.
Here we are in the twentieth
century, everything is
computerized and all that,
but you just want to know what
home prices have been doing in
the United States in the late
1980s and you couldn't find out.
There were some indexes,
but they were rather poor,
we thought, and not very
reliable.
We did our econometric work and
devised a method of repeat sales
method of home price indexes.
I wrote a book in 1993 called
Macro Markets about--it
talked a lot about index number
construction.
I said in the book that we need
to devise a home price index
that is as close as possible to
something like the S&P 500,
which is a stock price index.
The problem with home prices is
we have a much bigger
non-trading problem.
The S&P 500 is not very
out-of-date because stocks
usually don't go untraded for
more than a few minutes or maybe
a few hours at times.
With homes, the typical home
doesn't trade every ten years,
so we have a huge non-trading
problem.
What we did is we created an
index that was as close as
possible to a stock price index
so that it could be traded on a
financial market.
Then I had a student here,
Allan Weiss,
who said, why don't we get
going and get--my student was
graduating;
he was an SOM student--MBA
student.
He was graduating and he
thought we should produce these
indexes for sale for use in
financial markets,
so he wanted to do it.
He set up our company,
Case Shiller Weiss,
Incorporated,
and he ran it.
Now, Case and I were just on
the advisory--well,
we were on the board of
directors, but we were just
advising the operations.
I was so proud of him;
my student created the
Case-Shiller Home Price Indexes
and we started publishing them.
Then in early 1990s,
we traveled to all the futures
markets, proposing to them that
they create home price futures
based on our indexes.
It was disappointing;
we couldn't get anyone to do it.
I thought we had such a strong
case.
Shouldn't there be a futures
market?
We went to the--I mentioned the
coffee, sugar,
cocoa--we tried them all.
So, we'd go to these guys and
they're trading coffee,
sugar, and cocoa.
I said, look coffee is nice,
everyone wants their cup in the
morning, but we're talking about
twenty trillion dollars of
unhedged risk.
Most households in the United
States--that's what they own.
The typical household--they
don't own much stock;
they own real estate and they
can't hedge it.
I think we had the most
progress with the Chicago Board
of Trade;
they actually did some research
with us.
The funny thing that happened
was that CBOT did research in
1994 on whether they should set
up a futures market for
single-family homes.
The basic conclusion--they made
a lot of phone calls--that's how
they did research--asking
people,
are you worried about your home
price falling and would you like
to be able to hedge the risk in
the futures market the way
farmers do in the agricultural
market?
Basically, the answer was no
and people said,
I don't worry about my home
price falling.
So, they didn't want to start a
market because they thought--but
I was going around saying,
don't you know?
There's no law of economics
saying that home prices don't
fall.
They did--they have fallen;
they fell a lot in the
Depression and they could do it
again.
So, why don't people want to
have a market that would--they
don't just go steadily up.
But people said,
well the Depression--that was
so long ago;
we can't remember that.
So, we couldn't seem to get
anyone focused on it.
I think there's something about
this that we learned about the
origins of our current economic
situation.
We went around to a lot of
people trying to get them
interested in hedging real
estate prices.
Remember, the purpose of
futures markets is not gambling;
it's hedging;
it's protecting yourself.
I should write that term on the
board as well.
Hedging--I hope I made this
clear.
If you are running--let's go
back to wheat.
If you have a warehouse full of
wheat, you are a wheat
warehouser and you are like a
stable business.
So, what do you do?
You don't know what the price
of wheat is going to do;
it goes up and down
internationally.
So, what do you do?
You sell it in the futures
market and that means you've
hedged your risk of wheat
prices.
If wheat prices go down,
true the value of the stuff in
storage that you own is going to
go down,
but offsetting that is your
futures contract price,
which will go up,
and that hedging will protect
you.
You have reduced risk of your
business and this is done a lot.
Holbrook Working,
in the reading,
talks about that.
So, farmers also can hedge;
they've got wheat growing in
the fields and they're worried
about the price they can sell it
at, so let's lock it in today;
let's sell in the futures
market.
If the price of wheat declines,
your short position in the
futures market will appreciate
and offset your loss,
so you want to hedge your risk.
We went around asking people,
don't you want to hedge your
risk in the real estate market?
Unfortunately,
people are rather confused
about that and they're not used
to hedging that.
Anyway, with the recent boom in
home prices, we were able--we
finally approached the Chicago
Mercantile Exchange in 2006 and
said,
we want to work with you to
create--try to create--a futures
market for single family homes.
They said, okay let's try it.
So, this was what we did in May
of 2006;
we created a futures
market--not the very first,
there was an attempt in London
in 1991 that failed,
but we were essentially the
first futures market for
single-family homes in the
United States.
This market has been in
backwardation almost from the
first day.
When we opened the market in
May of 2006, our market maker,
who was brought in by the
Chicago Mercantile Exchange,
thought like everyone else who
reads the newspapers--well,
home prices just always go up.
So, the market maker put out a
bid-asked that implied contango
in the market--that home prices
would go up.
The market maker quickly
learned that there was no
market--contango market.
After losing a huge amount of
money, he pushed his bid-asked
spreads into the backwardation
range and left it there ever
since.
This shows the backwardation in
the futures market recently,
but it's been this way for a
couple years now.
So, what's going on in the
housing market?
I think that what has been
happening is that newspapers,
and real estate agents,
and lots of
commentators--people you see on
the news--have been telling us
that home prices always go up;
they've never fallen and don't
worry.
A lot of casual people have
believed that,
but the kind of people who
trade in futures markets didn't
believe it, even going back to
early 2006.
People who are ready to put
their money on the line have
been predicting a decline in
home prices now for two years.
You can see what dramatic
declines are being predicted in
our futures market.
I have it for various
cities--Boston,
Chicago, Denver.
We have separate markets for
each of the ten--of these ten
cities--Las Vegas,
Los Angeles,
Miami, New York,
San Diego and San Francisco.
The worst market of them all is
Miami and this market is
predicting almost a 35% home
price decline by November of
2012.
The second worst--what is the
second worst?
I can't quite read it;
they kind of merged here.
There's a bunch of cities where
the prediction is for a 20-25%
drop;
the best city of all is
Chicago, but even there they're
predicting a 7% drop.
So, we've seen a lot of
backwardation in that market.
I think this is reflecting the
unusual economic circumstance
we're in.
Finally, this is my last slide;
this shows the S&P
Case-Shiller Home Price Index.
That line is the actually home
price index and it has these
jumps in it every month;
that's because it's a monthly
index.
We only publish it every month,
but you can see that it's been
smooth.
It was increasing until around
the time we started the futures
market and then it's been
declining at an accelerating
rate.
We are now down in real terms
about 15% nationwide on home
prices, which peaked in early
2006.
This is the futures price that
we've had and that's for the
closest futures contract--the
nearest to expiration.
We're hoping to get a lot of
publicity for this because we
thought this was a very
interesting number.
This is futures market price
for homes and it moves around
day by day.
All those little wiggles
reflect new information that
came in on a particular day.
Unfortunately,
we have not been able to get
much attention for this number,
but there's been a lot of
attention to the S&P
Case-Shiller Home Price Indexes
now.
In fact, we're getting
newspaper stories all the time
written about our indexes,
but they don't write about our
market, so we've had trouble
getting a futures market
started.
It's going, but it's going only
at a low level.
I think that in the future this
will take off eventually and I
think that we'll have futures
markets for many more things.
Eventually, we'll have a
futures market for New Haven as
well.
Right now, New Haven is too
small to warrant its own futures
market.
So, I was thinking,
well someone in New Haven could
just buy two--if you wanted to
hedge your house,
you'd sell two New York
contracts and one Boston
contract.
I'm sort of interpolating
between New York and Boston,
but eventually we have to do
better than that and I'm hopeful
that there will be a day in my
lifetime when we'll see all
cities of the world traded on
futures market.
In my new book,
Subprime Solution,
I also claim,
and I think I have some basis
to say this,
that it will help reduce
bubbles and help reduce this
kind of instability.
Next period,
we're going to talk about
options and then we have only
one more lecture;
the last lecture on the
democratization of finance.